government - today we're gonna play
alone which is an oculus rift horror
game it's a game inside a game I
actually tweeted about it as a joke a
while back I doubt he got the idea from
me but it's pretty funny so let's check
it out
alright so I'm playing with a controller
I'm sitting on a couch I'm home playing
my xbox this is this is creepy just
fight this honestly it's so weird
alright let's play this game well my TV
is huge
I wonder what's gonna happen this is so
weird alright yay this probably looks
awful on YouTube the wind rattles why
was that garage lady I don't have time
for you right now I've had to lock the
main gate from to prevent uh-huh I left
the spare key near the gross keepers
shed okay it's actually kind of cozy I
like this this is way more spacious than
we're am sitting actually alright my
spare key huh nice very key bra it's
coming from upstairs I can't tell okay
alright we're going here this game
reminds me of that shitty shitty Silent
Hill game on the Vita is anyone ever
play that [ __ ] then I heard it a
terrible scream from the forest okay
cool sorry brah
hello I wasn't that terrible it was
pretty turned me on a little bit it
would be kind of cool if I walked in on
myself in the game every totaled mine
[ __ ] this is like aqil inception
whenever I'm the nurse in the nursery I
swear I can hear the voices of small
what don't whisper into my ears I don't
like it alright found a book in the
library today I dare not describe how it
is found on rap what what's that you
want to fight but come at me you think
I'm scared scared or nobody except my
mom she can be really skip knowledge
she's a wonderful lady the fair and
suspicion of the being bossy
what don't [ __ ] with me TV what is this
what someone is watching me
hello what what is that
no no oh it's me again
oh cool the exorcism was worthless stay
away and I you really picked a creepy
moment to like you're like
someone just bite my ass hope you're
happy yeah I could've died
my toes went right in the floor I think
I'm stuck right now you better be sorry
look what she does to me you're gonna
pay for this
alright well that was alone hope you
enjoy watching over like if you're dead
that's the Skycam right today
I'll see you next 1000 Brad alright oh
yeah once again wait what's that